welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain it is my privilege to
introduce you to dr. one Athiya dr.
Bhatia is an MD PhD whose research has
focused on new indications in
stereotactic radiosurgery and the search
for surgical treatment for drug
resistant or logical diseases in
particular in inter cerebal infusion of
anticonvulsant drugs neuro stimulation
and south therapy applied to
neurological diseases his research
projects include the regeneration of the
nitro Strider pathway with biomaterials
in Parkinson's disease models the use of
biomaterials for the repair of the
cerebral cortex the definition of
targets for brain stimulation using
brain connectomics and the induction of
brain plasticity for a complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen dr. Marcia is a professor and
head of the Department of Neurosurgery
Hospital cleaning of San Carlos and
Universidad Complutense a de my bloob
dr. Marcia's talk is titled inducing
cortical plasticity by brain stimulation
and rehabilitation my name is dr.
Veronica Shannon and I would be a
moderator for today's event we were
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab woods we
would like to extend our special thanks
to the brain initiative program
directors and in particular dr. James
Mack for their efforts in organizing
today's session before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting questions
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located at the
far left of your screen and type your
questions in the drop down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
by email following the presentation the
presentation is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. one Pavia hello
thank you very much for it be flotation
and I'm going to talk about how to
induce cortical plasticity by brain
stimulation and rehabilitation in order
to treat brain tumors and this is the
first part I will show you and it is
that the survival curves of a brain
tumors are strongly dependent on the
extent of resection for the very
aggressive gliomas a it is important to
take away the most of the tumor Cupido
sections in critical but in low-grade
tumors a complete resection can be
equivalent to creation but the problem
is that these tumors are very
importantly they it is very difficult to
tell where the tumor and inward normal
brain begins and it is not like in other
surgeries in the body for example in
abdominal surgery the surgeons can take
away the tumor and then cut the gut in
pieces and the pieces to the pathologist
and that until the pathologist says
there's no Mortimer but in the case of
the brain we try to make an extended
resection of a tumor for example the one
we have in the picture we would have a
problem with movement would have a mi
per se control at all hemiparesis and we
would have an aphasia because we are
going to damage the cortical spinal
tract and the arcuate fasciculus but
what if we could take away the functions
which are around the tumor to improve
they make a bigger resection so we are
going to talk about plasticity
plasticity was the first a pointed out
by santiago ramon akahl who was a
the Spanish the neuroscientists who
observed that mirrors can a increase
their contacts because he saw that a
that the differences between the weight
in children and in a lot in adults a
work cost not because neurons a divided
but because neurons increased their
connections but a broker showed us that
there are a certain areas in the brain
which are critical for speech production
and this is the a we use in the picture
the areas he described as the forecast
the area which is said important for a
motor language and carbonic a described
a similar area but for the understanding
for the reception of language and later
weather pencil made a map of the cortex
well he did a history epilepsy surgery
procedures and it seemed that everything
in the brain in the cortex is well
organized but it seemed also that
everything is fixed that all the
locations are there forever but a some
authors like a Michael Moore tonic in
the in animals we saw that a stealing
studying which is the representation of
the auditory functions in the cortex is
he was able to show that these
representations can change with
experience and this field has been also
a research by Alvaro Leone and other
authors but the Alvaro particularly
an experiment which is very interesting
for the things we are going to talk if
you see in the panel be in the middle a
he used he took a normal volunteers who
has never played piano and he measured
the cortical representation of the
fingers before they started to take
lessons of piano practice in town and he
sold in the first week at the beginning
that the representation was a small in
the one in the picture
but after five days of practicing the
representation drew a like a ten times
and they were sent how rest during the
weekend and they when he mastered at the
end of presentation it had strained but
the same size as the beginning of the
first week and after one week of
practicing with him and then he showed
that did Frank it rule it's Frankie drew
but at the end of the fifth week he saw
that the so-called man the effect was
greater and greater and the tried effect
was a lesser and lesser so he concluded
that there were some kind of stable
stabilization of plasticity in a very
short time so a which is the limit how
can we do to change a plasticity a
plasticity of course daily but with
changes in plasticity don't occur
because we our brain is very reluctant
to change because of learning and it
goes to the minimal states of but the it
would be possible to change the this
state of lower consumption thing
minimal energy if we push this state to
a peak and then by any means like
inhibition I'm going to show you and we
are able to make some put some factors
with which make the system go to another
state of minimal energy and this happens
naturally with a low grade tumors we
were shown a this paper that the tumors
which are operated they in which are
close to eloquent areas and are operated
a week with patient awake when there is
some eloquent function within the tumor
this tumor is left and after some years
when the patient's Rio paraded then the
location of this function has shift in
some way the tumor has shift has pushed
the cortical localization of the
function a way to an adjacent area or
even to control lateral areas so we
wondered if it could be possible to take
advantage of this principle to go faster
than what the tumor does he would it be
possible to artificially induced plastic
changes in in in cortical in the
representation of eloquent functions to
obtain better possibility to make
greater a removal of tumors and this was
a our first our first case was a 28 year
old a man who had this tumor it is the
area which is whitish in the in the left
lower frontal gyrus and this
mm so the representation of speech
function because it is obtained through
a functional magnetic resonance so a
this patient had been operated some
years ago 5 years ago and only a biopsy
could be taken it was under a treatment
with radiotherapy and chemotherapy but
him no longer tolerated the chemotherapy
because of a bone marrow a pleasure
so we operated the patient awake and we
only could take the area which is shown
in the picture the tanks which are
number areas which are a active with
function when we stimulate we can
produce speech of arrest or other
effects on language function so we
cannot take be serious away because they
are critical to progress to produce
speech so then we put in a grid over the
the cortex around the tumor and over the
the remainder of the tumor a this grid
is the one which is typically used in
surgery for epilepsy to find a epileptic
areas and in a chronic basis so we we
close the corner to me and the words
were coming out through the skin and
after one week we did a mapping within a
simulation again of this the areas of
the cortex using an external stimulation
and in yellow you can see areas which
are still holding a speed function so a
the tumor was filled a of the areas
which were critical for speech so we
started to inhibit these contacts using
an external stimulator with very high
frequency stimulation so every day we
calculated with
stressful to produce a speech arrest and
we know what this voltage to produce
only a very mild dysarthria a while the
patient was continually continuously
doing speech therapy and we could
observe that every day we could raise
the threshold so that the patient
recovered this speech function and he
was able to do speech therapy again and
again until until in which there was no
longer deficit so the Broca's area the
so called Broca's area was inhibited
completely but he would produce speech
normally and we did in functional remark
and you remember that the active area
was in the the left side which is in the
right side and be slight because of the
original convention and when we reach
this situation we did a control
functional mark and we saw that the
right hemisphere was a holding the
cortical function the eloquent function
and it was longer no longer represented
in the left side and a you know that
function in the mark can have a fails
false positives and negatives but when
we real operator the patient awake we
could observe that this image which were
a previously active were no longer
active so a we could perform a almost
complete a removal of the tumor and we
use this a this procedure to operate a
series of five cases this is the table
the data of the cases the pieces are a
little bit
a mysterious petal unions but a in all
cases the worst
tumor which was
a holding inside an eloquent area and we
did the same procedure for the
everything's so in this was published in
the Journal of neurosurgery in three
years ago and the general procedure is
like you see in the slide we operate
first patient reducing the standard
criteria we make a cortical maximum a
mapping will be patient awake and we
take only areas which are not eloquent
then we perform this so-called
rehabilitation procedure and after the
procedure will operate the patient again
using the same criteria and every time
we reopen it the patient would take more
and more chemo so a this is the summary
of our cases in in greatest areas which
are active before the procedure in jello
you see areas which are no longer active
after the procedure you here can see the
statistical differences when we analyze
the functional more in a four in this
case were generation in speed for action
so you see that there is a shift in the
location of the of the areas which are
active during production and this is
what happens before the surgery into the
to the left a the next picture is after
the first surgery you can take only very
small amount of tumor after the second
surgery and some few months after the
second surgery this is another case in
which we could a it was a very extensive
tumor and this is the statistical
differences and the effect of the
overall procedure with a very extensive
resection of the
read the sorry on the left the fronton
law this is the case of a humor located
inverted hysteria for speech perception
speech recognition and this is the
statistical differences this is the
procedure before after surgery and after
the second surgery and a this case
located in the primary motor area in
this case the function we was not helped
by the contralateral image field but it
was relegated the around in a decent
area and this is the overall view of the
resection procedure and this is the last
case in which a consisted a very big a
frontal tumor with a speech and motor
functions and this is the overall
procedure so a what we can do is to
improve the extent of resection and in
this first series we could make the
final residual volume less than 3
milliliters which is a criteria for
which a malignancy ession in love with
humour can start to happen so we could a
improve resection improve survival
maintaining a eloquent functions but the
main complications were a infection long
hospital stay and the time to stabilize
new speech or modern networks and this
was because patients have to be with
external stimulation for a long time so
our next step will be to use implanted
generators connected to grids so
continuously to improve this function it
helped this
the procedure has been repeated in other
hospitals for example to take a politico
coos in Boerne caesarea and probably the
next steps will be reduced this
procedure to improve brain machine
interfaces in rehabilitation for stroke
fortune and we have to see which is the
limit of our procedure because terribly
it will depend on the physical networks
which are holding your brain - thank you
very much this is my hospital and I
invite you to come whenever you want
thank you very much thank you dr. Marcia
for this excellent presentation on your
singular work in cerebral brain
plasticity as a reminder our speaker
will be following up any questions on
his presentation by email coming up next
please join us as Helen Bronte Stewart
presents her landmark work in
Parkinson's disease her talk is entitled
closed loop deep brain stimulation in
Parkinson's disease using patient
specific biomarkers and therapeutic
window